So 25 years.
Oh,
don't worry.
Animistic is a income is a wonderful
revenue for you.
So I told myself and told him,
my young people before 20 years old,
be a good student when into
entrepreneurialism.
Learn some experience before 30 years
old.
Follow somebody,
go to a small company.
Normally in a big company,
it is good to learn processing.
You are a part of a big machine,
but when you go to small company,
you learn the passion.
You learn the dreams,
you learn how to do lots of things as
when one time,
so before 30 years old,
it's not which company you go,
it's which boss you follow.
It's very important.
A good boss teach you differently and
before from 30 to 40 years old,
you have to think very clearly where
you're working for yourself.
If you really want to be an
entrepreneur,
when you're 40 to 50 years old,
you have to do all the things that you
are good at.
Don't try to drop into the new area.
It's too late.
You may be successful,
but the rate of dying is too big.
So 40 to 50 think about how can focus on
things that you are good at,
but when you are 50 to 60 years old,
work for the young people
because young people can do better than
you.
So rely on them.
Invest on them,
making sure they're good.
So when you are over 60 or so,
spend time for yourself on the beach
side.
Shine,
right?
It's too late for you to change novelty.
But I,
this is my,
my advice to the young people,
25 years old.
Make enough mistakes.
Don't worry,
you fall.
You stand up,
your fault,
your stem.
Enjoy it.
I mean,
25 years old.
I enjoy the show in your show.
I didn't.
I have a rich father,
tried to three times for university,
all filled.
I apply for Harvard for 10 times.
All failed.
They don't even want to see me for the
last time I went to the teacher's
college,
which was considered the third or fourth
class of my city.
So applied jobs 30 times rejected.
It was so difficult at that time.
I was so frustrated because I taught in
a university,
my pay was $10 a mouth because I cannot
find a good job in 1994 discuss it.
I'm going to do something called
Internet and 23 of them against it.
They said,
this is stupid idea.
We have never heard about internet or
you know nothing about computer and I
never thought I was smart.
Nobody believed that I could be
successful because everybody would say,
well this guy think differently.
Think of crazy that you know these
things about something that will work.
I try to follow three salary who has
daughters from the banks took me three
mouse,
but I still cannot get him.
We talked to over 30 or 40 of venture
capitalists.
Everybody's mill.
Forget it.
Not a pupil said Ali Baba is a terrible
model.
As I said,
I believe that.
I think this thing,
could it be big?
I never thought it will be bad big.
Like today I believe something,
something is waiting for me there and I
have to work hard to prove myself.
That was the tough experience.
So we gather 50,000 us daughters from 18
founders were started for the first
three years.
We do not have the evil $1 revenue from
our business.
What's not easy?
Why?
It keeps on going ahead going forward,
because I received lots of email of
thanks from the customer.
This a,
this is such a great thing we cannot
have pay you,
but this thing helped us.
If you keep on helping us one day you
will be successful and I believe this
little by little we build up our
business little by little we build up
our ecosystem of the infrastructure and
now after 16 years,
whoever Ali Baba Group,
we have a team or group,
we have a top all group where for Ali
pay and people fed.
You are so smart.
How could you make a company like that?
Bill Gates,
Warren Buffet,
the Jack Welch,
very page mark Sangaber.
The difference between those people and
other people,
they are always optimistic for the
future.
They never complained.
They always tried to solve the problems
of the others
where you're optimistic.
It's always opportunity.
People same here today.
Jeff,
where's the opportunity?
I don't have a job.
I don't have this.
I don't have a debt.
We are at the best of time of the
sanctuary.
The best,
uh,
sets you have is that you are young.
Don't complain.
Let the other people complain.
The opportunity lie always lies where
people complain.
Singing about how you can make things
different.
Is there anything I can do that make the
two first and then when you think about
this study to it,
I saw a lot of people,
young people have a fantastic ideas
every evening,
but in the morning they go to the office
thing.
Again,
being an entrepreneur,
you have to do the things before the
other people do.
You have to wake up before the other
people wake up.
You have to be more brave than the
others.
Use instinct.
Everything you do is to the need of the
customer,
to everybody,
to any person.
Tomorrow is a new,
make the move.
Make the action whether investors
believe it this or not,
whether your friends believe it or not,
what their parents believe it or not,
that's not important.
You believe it.
Your team believe in and work day and
night on this.
That's all the things happens.
Make enough mistakes.
You fall your stand up.
Any mistake is that encompasses.
Okay,
wonderful revenue.
Don't worry about it.
Money.
Money follows the people.
People should follow the creams.
If you have a dream just to go ahead.
I think nobody can conquer the world.
We're only kissed,
serve the world,
either work for the others.
I'll work for yourself and I troost away
or can my,
for myself working for myself.
That means working for the society.
If you really want to work for yourself,
think about the others because only when
the other people successful,
when the other people are happy,
you will be successful,
you will be happy.
I think today people worry a lot about
the world,
about the economy,
China economy in the world and I'm a
very optimistic when people start to
worry that that is the opportunity is,
but I worry about the blood testing and
she created the good things and I think
great innovations,
great companies always happening in the
tough times.
The lives,
like the music,
you have a copy of it down,
you have a lawyer,
the shot nodes,
and I like your American movie life.
Life is like a box of chocolate.
You never know what you're going to get.
Right?
So I'm pretty optimistic.
The opportunity in the future for
equality is huge because in the,
in in the last century,
the t is for big companies.
The globalization is for big companies.
But now with the technology,
we can serve those 80% of the companies
that never been served.
We can serve the 80% of the young people
that have never been served.
Technology for Internet is so cheap,
so easy to use.
One of the reasons why we grow each
China ecommerce so fast,
much faster than the u s it because our
infrastructure of commerce in China was
too bad.
Where does too bad?
Something happened to ghost.
Today we are working on the rural areas
of China.
I can never imagine that Chinar about
800 million people still live in the
rural areas.
Uh,
farmers and there are about close to 200
million people.
They are income is less than $1 per day
and before the Internet it's impossible
for these guys to reach the pc because
it's so difficult.
Even people like me,
I don't know how to use a pc,
but now all 80% of the farmers,
those people using mobile phones,
we have the mobile phones,
the Internet,
the data,
things changing a lot.
So I'm excited about the future.
People always worry.
That's the,
you know,
I love the young kids sitting there and
talking about the dream,
the hopes because if they have the hope,
we have the hope.
That's what I believe.
And let's just take
what you do.
And I
loved every description I've ever heard
about how you serve people and your
story about the bamboo farmers and your
wife and her friends.
It was fabulous.
But where's this going?
What are you going to do?
What are your plans to maximize the use
that people in remote rural areas of
China can make of their cell phones?
Besides ordering your projects,
how do you going to get it?
Are you going to get them in the banking
system through cell phones?
How
well,
um,
we,
we never know that we couldn't grow so
fast that passed the five miles.
We covered 4,500 villages and these
people normally the,
the using very traditional way.
Did it take them like two,
we went to a rural area,
it took them the farmers two hours to
work to the downtown,
uh,
in,
in the middle of the town and buy
things.
But today because the mobile phone and
we deliver,
we can deliver things to their home,
to their village within 72 hours.
I remember there is a,
well last week I read a very interested
in new for this is amazing.
There is a girl,
she told them your story.
She said her grandfather 92 years.
So the birthday and for his life he
always wanted to try one western style
food,
but he lived in the rural areas.
There's a no such a restaurant food.
So she said,
I tried on the Internet book a
restaurant,
dinner for western food,
deliver to that village and the fatherly
immediately find the one restaurant.
There were three guys,
they took like a three days bus from
the,
from Sha height to that village,
made a telic spaghetti and a beef for
that for 92 years old bursting and whole
village was excited.
Everybody starts says,
wow,
you can order food rest in a restaurant,
rest of style of food.
So by almost everything,
and also we'll helping there.
A lot of farmers,
they planned a love apples,
green apples,
but 90% of the apples routed because
there's nobody by that they normally buy
by track.
You know,
if you sell via the APP apples,
this our whole track
and
using the traditional way they can,
they can sell by whole basket of the
apples.
But now because of the Internet,
the cell by one by one,
each app with the cell,
$1 Oh you know,
won't imb or two,
I'm just for each.
So the farmers will see using Internet,
they can buy and the sell and using a
mobile phone that changed their lives.
And I think it's exciting and people
need examples when they see where the
other my neighbor made made money sort
of online to selling things.
My neighbor made by much interesting
things are life.
People start to learn and more more
people started by the mobile phones.
We cannot have,
we cannot make all the factory,
the mobile factories to cell phones to
them only they know the mobile phone
really works helping change their lives.
They started by the mobile phones.
Just one more question.
Do you think this will make
the current problems like the current
problem in China?
Less likely.
That is if we'll have more market
information in the market will drive
where the investment goes instead of the
government trying to make judgments
about it.
I better build another housing
development or office development here,
there and Yonder and you wound up with a
bubble.
What he comes from the bottom up.
Is it more likely that fewer bad things
will happen?
Yeah,
no.
I think the last week I was in Seattle
discussing about the China economy.
I think the you American people worry
too much about the China economy.
Well,
you see
every time where you start to worry
about the China,
China goes better.
Every channel you think China's problem,
you know we've got,
you know,
we'll get better but we ain't got to say
gi.
We have a,
you have a high expectation of China.
China always a problem like a parents of
the expectation of the kids,
you know have the same.
But there's a big difference between the
American consumption because people say
wow,
you know the economy's bad.
So China consumption will be good.
Look no totally different.
You American love to spin a tomorrow's
money
and the other people's money,
maybe all maybe the coolest money.
We Chinese love to safe money.
We are probably the largest or country,
the d safe deposit in the whole road.
That will people,
cause we'd been poor for so many years
when we made money,
we're putting the banks because Sunday
we know the disaster is coming so we can
spend the money.
So when the economy's bad,
we still have the money to spend.
You guys probably don't you worry.
And a second of thing at the China
market,
China been focusing on developing for
the past 30 years.
China government,
sole Straw on investment.
So Straw on exporting,
but they're too weak on the domestic
consumption's domestic consumption is
not driven by government,
is driven by intrepreneurship,
driven by the market,
not the government.
So in the past two years,
pastor to the years government is so
strong now they get a week.
It's our opportunity.
It's our show time to see the market
cademy entrepreneurship,
how we can develop the real consumption.
You know,
I think if the China developed with a
great consumption,
we have a 300 million middle class in
next to 15 to 20 years.
We've got a half below middle class.
We need to import a lot.
So when we start to import,
that's a great,
it's going to I,
I worry a lot when we export.
You know,
when we export,
we got a terrible sky.
We have a terrible water,
we have a terrible work environment.
When we started input,
we got to be better.
So that's all the grid opportunity guys.
Be Happy about that.
I'm serious.
We Orient Yourself,
don't worry.
The reasons.
Some of it's worried about China as we
depend on you to buy our debt.
However,
I tried to be more Chinese when I was
president,
I saved a lot of money.
So,
uh,
I just wanted you to say that because
I really believe that.
I mean,
I think you're absolutely right.
The trend toward greater internal
consumption is I think will remain
unbroken in spite of whatever the
difficulties are in the next few months.
I think it's important not to overreact.
You can't break the trend.
You got to clean up the land from
chemical contaminants.
You got to clean up the air,
you're going to do it.
Yeah.
And a lot of Chinese will make a lot of
money out of that will be a lot of great
new companies and there'll be
opportunities to import from other
places.
Yeah.
So
can you discuss your theory of what
you're doing and other things in terms
of whether it advances equal opportunity
in social solidarity?
Tell him what you think's going to
happen and what other kinds of,
when your opening remarks,
you just say,
uh,
technology is going to be active in this
way and other areas of the economy.
What do you think the next big
opportunities are?
But first tell him just in two sentences
what you're doing.
Cause Jack and I know when we haven't
been clear enough,
explain it and explain how you think
that advances social solidarity and
equality of opportunity.
Well,
our work is in
the belief that access to health
information is a basic human right and
that lab information,
particularly because lab data drives 70%
of clinical decisions needs to be
accessible to people before they're
sick.
And so if you look at the word diagnose
in the dictionary today,
it says to determine the presence of
disease from symptoms,
which means by definition we're
determining that people are sick once a
disease has already progressed.
And our work is in being able to make
lab testing accessible to people in time
for therapy to be affected.
And to do that in a way in which every
person you're respective of their
insurance status,
irrespective of where they live,
can afford the ability to get a test
done.
So that means in our case,
we've invested the last 12 years in now
developing hundreds of tests,
many of which are less than $10.
So in $2 tests in the United States.
And I think one of the amazing things
about this country is that we have such
an incredible
ecosystem for fueling creativity in that
creativity can create new markets.
So in answer to your question about the
market being able to conform itself to
social good,
I think the creativity that goes into
creating new these new technologies
create new markets in and of themselves.
And,
and our basic belief that is that those
new markets come from empowering
individuals and in franchising
individuals and trusting that
individuals have the capability to
engage with information and in accessing
that information,
beginning to take control of their own
outcomes and their own health outcomes.
And in doing so,
changing the way our healthcare system
works.
I think what this could mean for rural
China.
Yeah.
For Rural India,
for native American reservations in
America,
for the Mississippi Delta,
for the remote area to where all the
jobs for loss from cold,
you're all of a sudden giving people
information and uh,
one of the most important things I think
we did in my second term as president of
the healthcare front was developed as
Diabetes Self Care Program.
And all of a sudden you could be Jack's
company could be delivering the means to
self care based on your test.
I mean,
I think that this is really,
this is a very big deal.
We all want to live as long and as well
as we can.
And Greg Brenner was here.
We were joking about whether we'd make
it to a hundred but in the meanwhile,
do you want to keep people healthy?
And if they're sick,
you went to intervene early,
not late.
Sure.
When,
and if you look at,
I mean the ability to engage with this
information.
We have a $4 trillion health care
problem in this country.
20% of it is type two diabetes,
which is reversible.
And we 90 million Americans who do not
know they are prediabetic,
but access to information and the
ability to engage with that information
is the foundation for being able to
change those outcomes and costs.
Right.
One more factor then I want to call it
Jack,
you founded this company 12 years ago,
right?
Yeah.
Tell him how old you are.
I was 19
so
don't worry about the future.
We're in good hands and that was think
of a new [inaudible] water.
Where am nine tab?
Not The past examination for university
yet.
I felt a three times,
but I think it worked out.
I'm not good at schooling.
Well,
yeah.
That's why I give confidence to a lot of
young people in China.
If Jack Ma Can,
success can be successful.
80% of the people can be successful.
People like hurry up with jealous.
Well,
equality.
I would like to make a lot of technology
helping you because yesterday I was
joining the United a u n a woman
conference about gender equality and I
think the first,
the technology revolution happened 200
years ago in the UK.
Release the human body,
the arm stronger.
The second the technology revolution
that in the,
in the u s if our advantage you can last
law.
But this technology of revolution relief
release the brain.
So this century is not a competition.
Who's strong,
who's muscles stronger is who is a
smarter,
who's soft,
who can listen.
It's the challenge of a wisdom.
So man,
women are equal on the Internet.
You can never see his a woman or man on
the Internet.
Women can serve much better than the men
on the Internet and a man talking about
a business,
talking about,
you know,
numbers,
competition,
the nic business,
very code women,
they can make business a very cozy
lifestyle and interesting.
50% more than 50% of our shop owners,
while they half 5 million shop owners
are women.
And people love that.
I think this is,
this is a great thing.
I see that this century,
we see more and more women leaders on
the state leaders and the presidents in
the future.
We're going to general receptor of
United Nations should be a woman leader
at this is the greatest century for
equality.
And I,
I feel excited about that.
Let me ask you that.
We're almost out of time,
but one of the things that we haven't
talked enough about here,
not just here,
but generally is whether the leap
frogging we saw
with cell phones,
which was instrumental in your
phenomenal business success and which
will make it possible for you at the
appropriate time to do what you've done
on a global scale hitherto unimaginable
and all of human history for anybody to
have any of their own health data.
We haven't,
we've seen examples but not the kind of
dramatic penetration we need with energy
and clean energy and enough and in short
enough time to avoid the worst
consequences of climate change.
So do you believe
that,
I mean your country has done more than
anybody else to try to put up solar
panels and some of your companies went
broke because you overdid it,
right?
But beforehand and you got to work out
the phase out of the coal,
the phases of the sun and all that.
Meanwhile,
Africa,
which is growing like crazy because of
the cell phone and no small measure.
And as six of the fastest growing
countries in the world still has vast
swath of its land,
totally dark at night.
Do you believe
that it's possible for us to scale up
with distributed solar power is rather
than central lives as quickly as we did
with the cell phone?
And if so,
and if that were your business,
if you had to quit what you're doing
today and start there,
how would you do it and how would you do
it?
Did he at first I know that,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm such a huge believer in technology
and I think especially right now we're
at an incredible time in terms of new
technology and the ability to apply
technology in a scalable way towards
solving some of these problems.
So I would look at it in the context of
some of the renewable solutions that we
already have and in the context of
empowering,
connecting individuals with access to
those solutions and in the context of
creating markets around them,
I think that there's real opportunity to
actually create an ecosystem in which
people can financially benefit from
these solutions.
And I think that's going to drive an
adoption.
I think in developing economies there's
a revenue stream associated with that
and the more we can turn even already
some of the technologies that we have
into markets,
the more that we can fuel,
I believe local growth and individual
engagement in in beginning to adopt some
of these solutions.
Just related to that would be Jack,
you answer it and then I'll ask you one
final.
Yeah.
I am a strong believer that technology
can make war much better because people
say China economists getting slower,
I'm happy about a 7% even 5% even 5% of
the GDP of the number of chain of the
second large economy is big enough.
But yet you don't expect China keep on
growing 11% cause like one body,
one human body where your 1.8 meters
tall,
you cannot keep all like a 10% growth
every year.
You have to grow the quality,
your mind,
the wisdom.
So I think China needs new technologies
to solve this problems and which today
the data,
the,
the clean technology,
all these things that China is supposed
to do.
If we keep on the tradition,
the old ways,
we're going nowhere.
This is why I feel excited because
people asking you what is your dream
now?
Cause I never thought I would be today.
I can sit here talking to president.
I'm like a guy you know,
on the street and like filled of three
times for university,
five times four h for high key schools.
I applied for 10 times and Harvard
school or rejected.
I never thought because of the tech and
large because the Internet,
it give me this opportunity.
So I'm think when I retire,
I don't want,
the Chinese people have a terrible water
to drink and it's safe for food and the
money we make all spend in the hospital.
That's disaster.
So how we can use in the technology to
enable young people the greater chance
of this road.
Don't worry about.
We got to 1.4 billion people who are
born in 1980s they are the people of the
Internet Times.
They are going to have new ways to solve
the word problems.
The things you're worried about today,
they can solve it.
And a human being have the these kind of
worries for centuries.
Uh,
young people can always solve it and
today when you have the right direction,
cling encourage,
you know,
the,
the climate change,
all these issues they will be solved and
these are the great opportunities ahead
of us.
Anything else?
I agree with that.
I think the more,
the more we can,
the more we can in franchise people,
the more we can create ecosystems in
which individuals are empowered,
the more we give rights to individuals
to be able to build businesses,
to be able to,
to pursue the economic benefit of
technologies.
The more you see these markets change
before they leave the stage,
I want you to look at them
and I want you to think about the time
we have had to spend here
dealing with the refugee problems in
Syria and Lebanon.
Stand up.
Ellis,
this is my friend Elliot Musafa.
He's the education minister in Lebanon.
He's got to educate all these kids
and
so he left a miracle that very much
reflects the lives that Elizabeth and
Jack have lived.
He was
in a very responsible position at the
American of Dubai.
They started bringing American scholars
over there to live in and and Arabic
culture.
He did all these wonderful things.
Lebanon got in trouble.
He went home to save his country.
What is the difference?
How much more could he in every smart
Lebanese person do if they could focus
on these things and why can he not?
Because the place is dominated by people
who think their differences are more
important than their common humanity and
our common challenges.
You cannot imagine
Jack Miles proud of being Chinese.
I like that.
He never hit it.
He's,
he's happy about it and the proud to be
a global citizen.
I imagine Elizabeth's proud to be a
blonde haired,
blue eyed American tech.
No.
Where's the northern California?
Yes,
but
they don't,
not a word either.
One of them is sad,
has defined the meaning of their lives.
Are the direction of their work with
negative reference to someone else.
My friend Dikembe Mutombo stand up.
No,
you don't have to stand up.
It'll hurt too much.
You're an old man.
My seven foot two or it's fall friend
was just inducted into the National
Basketball Association Hall of fame
and
my family,
my whole family loves him and I have
seen how much he has given back to his
native country Congo,
which has been sold troubles.
I've known him a long time.
We both went to Georgetown University.
I did before he was born.
I think I've never heard him say a
resentful thing about anybody.
I have seen him give and give and give
and try to give the people in his native
land opportunities.
Why am I telling you this?
He's had a good life because he never
defined his life with negative reference
to anybody else.
He never begrudge anybody else's success
and he thought he had an obligation to
help other people.
I'm telling you,
this is the,
we are back in a time of collective
global insecurity
where
the main struggle is the oldest one in
human history.
Just in modern techno realities.
I mean if you were trying to build the
Middle East,
you would think about our permanent
sponsor here.
The ambassador from Oman who tried to,
her government tried to help head off a
calamitous war in the Middle East over
the nuclear issue in Iran.
We all pray to God that it will work
and the lady she made you look around
all these places,
wherever
people are putting aside their
differences and working together,
good things are happening.
We cannot achieve economic or social
equality without living in the factual
realities of the world.
We face looking at the obstacles,
looking at the opportunities,
making the best decisions and those of
us who even feel good about ourselves
because we think we spend a lot of time
giving.
Our whole goal should be to work
ourselves out of a job.
One of the things that the bill and
Tammy Austin it or sitting there with
stark and they started giving away
hearing aids and then they decided,
well we better teach these young people
how to speak.
It's I get the gift of hearing.
They'll have to learn that.
So they got into the education distance.
Sani Barky got into the education
business and started somebody ought to
do something really dramatic to remind
people that the only people that really
matter,
the teachers,
so he gave the first global teacher of
the year award last year and an
international panel gave the prize to a
teacher from Maine who probably gave the
entire million dollars to her school
woman,
never made any money in her life.
She gave all the money away
immediately.
The future's going to be forged by
people who think of how to use the
modern tools that we're given
as Elizabeth and Jack have to create
opportunity through empowerment.
And it will not be a straight line.
It's too,
too many moving parts.
But I just want you to think about that.
The reason you feel good looking at them
and that you identify with them even
though they're different from you.
And that's basically where we are all
over again and we can't slip back.
We can't give up.
That's why we had the prime minister of
Italy and George Soros talking about the
future of Europe.
And George said it was coming apart and
the prime minister said,
no,
it doesn't have to come apart if it's
about something more than economics.
I thought it doesn't have to come apart
if you will.
It not to,
and you put yourself on the line for it.
There are no guaranteed outcomes today,
but you can guarantee that the trend is
right.
So go ahead.
You were gonna say something origin.
I just wanted to add,
I mean it's,
we were talking about the future and,
and my own experience
and looking at all the faces here.
I think a huge part of the answer to
your question is also to raise our
little girls with the stereotype that
they can be the best in engineering and
science and math because when they do,
in all of these industries,
it changes everything.
And
we need to do that in this country and
we need to do that as parents in other
countries.
Yeah.
I was thinking about if,
uh,
what you say,
I'll think about when you,
what,
when you talk about the problems you're
normally is like a politician.
When you talk about the opportunities
that the business people,
I was thinking about how we can,
using this,
all the problems that change the problem
become the opportunity.
And um,
I,
I dunno,
I just feel excited when people talk
about problems.
I think that's thing about if you can
solve one of them,
that's the chance.
And today nobody in live in this century
has so many opportunities and so many
tools they can use the change other
people's lives.
And I think in,
in the last century,
which I'd call it time,
this century is called the [inaudible]
data technology.
It is to empower yourself,
make yourself strong.
D t is to empower the others.
When you pee,
empower the others,
you're empowered your future or
yourself.
So when I listen to talk,
I agree and I think,
uh,
that's why we were born in this century.
That's why we,
uh,
how we can use the internet to help
them.
What people,
it's giving them a hand.
Thank you.
Okay.